clear up a bunch of things for me first
of all someone tells me 20 minutes if
you wait the coronavirus will die on a
surface then someone told me 72 hours so
in general when the virus is dried it
can live for hours sometimes a little
bit more on surfaces that doesn't mean
it's infectious so if you look at almost
all the cases in the United States China
and Korea they were spread by droplets
droplets happen when you breathe and
when you cough and so on surfaces
doesn't seem to me the dominant mode of
spread that's not to say there's not a
little bit of virus there but in general
no and this virus you know it's got a
surrounding that is so sensitive to
alcohol and soap so you wash it with
alcohol or Purell it's clean the virus
is dead all right so if I'm in New York
and I'm getting food deliveries what do
you think of the idea of putting the
food in the microwave oven for 20
seconds listen the best way to do it is
that your delivery person comes you put
a pair of gloves on you take the back
you put it on one place on the counter
you take the food out put it on a plate
throw the bag away and wipe the counter
with a detergent and then you're fine
okay I'm on the food it's not gonna live
on the foot we're not getting food
transmission of the virus and so so in
concern the microwave if you want it hot
but I wouldn't worry about eating food
some of us are thinking that you need
hot water to wash your hands does the
temperature of the water matter does not
matter when you saw guys like Jim Baker
going around talking about this silver
solution is the cure that's all [ __ ]
right yes it's all [ __ ] anything you
read on the internet that you know is
not comically there's no secret cure out
there there's no secret prevention
there's no secret pill to take there's
no secret test that somebody is selling
that the government doesn't have all of
that is [ __ ] if I catch the virus
can I catch it again the answer to that
is we just don't know yet because the
first case this virus happened in
December so what we do know is that for
a month or two you can't what's gonna
happen a year two three years from now
we just don't know my gut is like other
coronaviruses you're probably going to
be immune but we don't know the answer
yet should we be wearing masks we've
heard that the mask is [ __ ] so the
virus is very small the best mask is
called an n95 mask the 95 means that it
filters out 95% of part of
in the air the virus can actually go
through it so the vibe the mask can
block droplets most Asian countries when
you coughed you wear a mask so you don't
expel droplets to others so wearing a
mask if you don't have the virus isn't
gonna do very much at all I'll give you
some rumors that I heard I can't take
ibuprofen that's not true
if you drink warm water that's another
one it will you know not let the virus
get into your lungs that's not true
either
what is it we're gonna look like when no
one can dye their hair anymore a lot of
people we're gonna see real true aging
aren't we yes and that's that's what I'm
afraid of